[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben schön dass sie wieder
mit dabei seit heute gibt es nur richtig
leckere und originelle beilage das sind
user brötchen mit lecker gewisser
hähnchen und leckerer joghurt eben oben
drauf wir benötigen zwei pakete yoga
teig das ist dieser drei extra deswegen
türkischen supermarkt außerdem drei
ganze hähnchenbrustfilets weil fein
gehackte zwiebeln 2 2 esslöffel milch
eine special paprikapulver ein teelöffel
salz sowie ein viertel teelöffel treffer
sicher zwei es für spaßvögel und
anderthalb esslöffel butter
ich habe in meinem kochtopf das wasser
erhitzt und gäbe da die
hähnchenbrustfilets hinein
das lasse ich dann eine aufkochen und
bei mittlerer hitze blick hat 30 minuten
lang garen
[Musik]
sobald das fleisch dann durch ist wird
das überschüssige wasser abgegossen das
solltet ihr aber noch nicht wegschütten
das doch die eventuell später nochmal
als nächstes werden die
hähnchenbrustfilets feind dann können
wir den gleichen topf wieder verwenden
dort geben wir die butter hinein und
rüsten die zwiebeln er wird dann das
vorbereitete fleisch hinein gegeben und
mit geraten
[Musik]
jetzt werden noch die gewürze also
balver und paprika flocken gut unter
berührt somit ist die füllung auch schon
fertig und jetzt kann das ganze
eingeräumt werden
dafür gebe ich einfach tickets bei einer
füllung auf mein opa blatt und rolle das
ganze zur spitze hinein
die fertige rolex gebe ich dann auch mal
mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech
hier habe ich gemerkt und freuen uns mit
dem blatt deswegen einfach alles
zurechtrücken und die brics schön auf
das faktische anschließend wird die
oberfläche der bereich moz mit einer
mischung aus eiern und milch verstrichen
hier habe ich zwei kleineren größe
entwickelt aber auch 1 begrüße entnehmen
bestreift das ganze und dann darf das
auch schon in den backofen bei 190 grad
20 minuten außerdem habe ich hier noch
400 m naturjoghurt da gehe ich jetzt
noch salz pfeffer und eine knoblauchzehe
1 und verhöre das ganze miteinander
die fertigen bedeckt werden jetzt noch
halbiert oder gedreht wo wir das
genießen wird und anschließend auf einen
teller gelegt um das ganze geschmacklich
abzurunden gebe ich dann dazwischen
immer von den joghurt drauf was ich hier
noch drauf verteile das ist die
hühnerbrühe die wir zum anfang noch
übrig hatten
das könnt ihr auf verteilen wenn ihr
doch ganz sicher haben möchtest aber
kräftiger mag der lässt sich lieber sein
und was jetzt doch ganz schöne für die
optik ein paar paprika flocken und
getrocknetem insel wie könnt ihr darüber
verteilen und damit eure aufregende und
leckere beilage auch schon fertig als
ich das rezept für feine hat dann freut
sich sehr über euer kommentar und über
ein abo und ich sagte zum nächsten lauf
ließ kitchen
[Musik]